[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
a cave or are Italian by now you know
that between mid-november and
mid-December 2022 the World Cup was
being held in Qatar or as many call it
the World Cup of Shame why well because
it has been held in an authoritarian
country without democracy and where
human rights are conspicuous by their
absence in Qatar the law is based on
Sharia the Islamic law for example
homosexuality is forbidden and
persecuted but perhaps we can find
something terribly questionable
reprehensible and directly related to
this world cup and that has been the
lack of Labor rights of immigrant
workers in many cases we could even call
it slavery that is why all the media
Outlets have condemned what is happening
in Qatar now one thing we must ask
ourselves is where does legitimate
concern for human rights end and
posturing begin because let's be clear
Qatar has always been like this even
when Barcelona players wore this jersey
when Barcelona football club won the
Champions League seven years ago tens of
millions of petrodollars came out of
Qatar to pay the salaries of Messi
Neymar Savvy and Company at that time
Qatar already had the slavery regime or
as they call it the cathala and that's
not all did you know that Qatar is not
the only country where we can find this
system take a look at this map
there are seven other countries that
still use it to a greater or lesser
extent Saudi Arabia Bahrain United Arab
Emirates Jordan Kuwait Lebanon and Oman
in general all these countries have the
same problems regarding the lack of
Labor rights that we can find in Qatar
but pay attention because it's not only
the Arab Petro monarchies that can be
condemned for the kafala system since
this issue involves such surprising
participants as the Ugandan government
and what does Uganda have to do with it
over the course of the video we're going
to explain the whole situation the truth
is that there are many half truths about
kathala for example I'm sure many of you
have in mind this exclusive article
published a year ago by the British
newspaper the guardian revealed 6500
migrant workers have died in Qatar since
World Cup awarded it is clear that the
headline clearly seeks to link the dead
workers to the World Cup concession the
problem is that not all immigrants in
Qatar are involved in construction to
begin with there are many domestic
staffs drivers hotel workers and in
short all kinds of service Personnel
because let me tell you that you will
never see a Qatari sweating in their
tunic
[Music]
500 are deaths in general not deaths
that we should attribute directly to
occupational accidents so that's a very
sensationalist headline but don't take
my word for it instead take a look at
what Dr Andreas Krieg of King's College
London says the guardian's original
report was with 6500 deaths over 10
years among 1.4 million migrant workers
a year from five countries out of 1
million young men under the age of 25
560 die each year in Germany I.E 5 600
in 10 years Dr Andreas Creek clearly
seen in this light the figure is not
that remarkable but this is not to
downplay labor abuses or to say that
Qatar is a worker's Paradise not at all
what we want to underline is that in
order to see the scope of the kafala
problem it is necessary to know what the
real situation of Labor rights is in
these countries and also to analyze
whether or not they have done anything
to eradicate this abusive system what is
clear is that with half truths nothing
is achieved in today's video we will
draw attention to details that often
escape the debate and that are of
interest for forming an opinion that
goes beyond a catch for rate so the
question is what is a kafala and how
does it work how do these Persian Gulf
countries get their labor as the World
Cup really serve to drive reforms in
Qatar as FIFA Advocates or are they
exaggerating
[Music]
last Bastion of slavery
[Music]
the kafala dates back to the bedumi
traditions of the gulf Arab countries
according to their Customs the host of
foreign visitors assumed legal and
economic responsibility for these
visitors as their cafeel in Arabic means
sponsor or guarantor the idea was that
these hosts or sponsors were responsible
for everything for their guests both for
the good and the bad that is if a
foreigner visited you you sought a bit
that he or she lacked nothing now if
that guest of yours turned out to be a
thief the responsibility also fell on
you in theory it doesn't sound so crazy
does it however this ideal of the kafala
system changed completely when Qatar
became a British protectorate in 1916.
[Music]
the current kafala system understood as
a mixture of immigration laws and
policies was the creation of the British
Empire which enjoyed great influence in
the Persian Gulf during the first half
of the 20th century this system allowed
the British to bring in a lot of
colonial subjects from different corners
of the Empire especially from South Asia
as you can imagine all this was
especially useful after the oil boom
[Music]
in 1971 Qatar got rid of the British
protectorate and became an independent
country and that's when they said hey
it's a good idea to have people from
India coming to work so like the seven
countries mentioned before Qatar
maintained the kafala system and molded
it into the kind of modern slavery we
know today as a result many of the
immigrants who arrived in these
countries need a feel to take
responsibility for their legal status
and depending on the case they may come
to depend on him for everything
many of the immigrants who come to work
in countries under the Catholicism
system often complain that their wages
fall far short of what is Promised they
are even forced to work for months at a
time even though they are not being paid
at all there are also complaints that
employers look for any pretext to
confiscate part of the salary Marathon
working hours and almost no rest
[Music]
but not only that the kefir can also
confiscate your passport in other words
in some cases they not only exploit you
but they can force you to stay in the
country in other words you are forced to
work whether you want to or not that
sounds like slavery yeah slavery
although this problem seems to mainly
affect unskilled immigrants from India
or Bangladesh it can also affect
well-known footballers Zahir balunis
returns to France after 17-month kafala
dispute with Qatari Club al-jayish in
this case we're talking about a French
footballer who was held for 17 months in
Qatar International pressure made it
possible for balloonists to leave
unfortunately others do not have so much
support
[Music]
now the most perverse thing of all is
that in the old days if you wanted
slaves you invaded a territory captured
your enemies and then put them to work
in your service until their last breath
today in the middle of 2022 it is the
slaves who come to you in some countries
this has become a social alarm take a
look at what Rodrigo duterte said a year
ago when he was still president of the
Philippines we called on the world
system
foreign because the Filipino is no slave
and to anyone anywhere the kafala has no
place there
because it's a setup
for slavery
either you correct it or we
will ask our workers Filipino workers
to go home okay it is true that bringing
out duterte to defend human rights seems
like a curious fast but man for a ruler
to speak out against kafala we had to
bring him out because what he says here
is spot on
this is the reality of these countries
with their oil and gas exploitations
these countries have hyper fortified
themselves and demand more and more
labor so there is kind of tacit social
pact the local population is a small but
very powerful minority they are the
citizens who benefit from the Privileges
financed by the state's energy wealth in
Qatar they number around 380 000
represented about 10 percent of a
population of nearly 3 million while the
rest the non-citizens are the migrant
workers they are the vast majority in
the country and the trend continues
unabated look at 2022 katara's
population surges by 13.2 percent with
huge influx of foreign workers if you
are a Qatari citizen you don't even need
to work you have your businesses your
Investments the state gives you a lot of
facilities land cheap credit but the
hard work is done by immigrants and the
vast majority come mainly from Asian and
African countries under the kafala
system of course the burning question is
but how do they manage to attract
workers who know they are going to be
enslaved to a certain degree we're going
to take a look at that right now
[Music]
the Arabian dream
Let's Travel for a moment to Kerala a
state in India with a huge population no
less than 35 million people and a very
young population to boot well there they
have a problem that nobody could imagine
a lack of Labor in the hospitality
industry why is that because more than 2
million keralites 17 of the working
population are already working abroad
mainly in Qatar and other Arab Nations
what they can earn there close to one
thousand dollars a month is six times
what they can earn in similar jobs in
Kerala and that makes them willing to
pay a bundle to recruitment agencies to
get them a job and a good feel in these
countries how much money are we talking
about well look closely at the following
graph
[Music]
the dashed horizontal line marks one
month's earnings and the bars represent
the number of monthly payments that
migrant workers have to pay back for the
ability to be able to work in the kafala
country in question as you can see it
costs bangladeshis and pakistanis an arm
and a leg because they are charged a
fortune for the Visa
[Music]
yet despite these costs and risks
hundreds of thousands of people continue
to migrate legally to the Middle East
each year there in many cases they
endure abusive conditions but what they
earn is a small fortune in their home
countries this money is used on their
return to start up businesses to earn a
living It's A Hard Road but an
alternative for Escaping The Misery of
their countries of origin some even
managed to set up businesses within the
Arab countries themselves and I know
what many of you are thinking are there
recruitment agencies doing business with
the kafala how barbaric well wait a
minute there is another player who is
becoming responsible for many human
rights violations
[Music]
because in Africa there are countries
where it is their own government that is
sending its citizens there this is the
case of Uganda the minister of Labor
herself Betty amongi explains to you why
the government of Uganda has a problem
for what they call Labor Outsourcing she
talks about annual data coffee export
brought to this country
559 million dollars remittances
from externalization of Labor brought us
about 900 million
US Dollars African labor is gaining
prominence in kefala countries because
the workers are willing to do the same
work as Asian staff but for less money
to give you an idea in 2021 alone 85 000
ugandans participated in the labor
Outsourcing program to Saudi Arabia
Qatar and the United Arab Emirates the
Ugandan government is well aware that in
the Persian Gulf countries there are
abusive situations for their expatriate
workers but they also understand that
they will earn much more money for their
work than if they stay in their own
country it is therefore a question of
priorities and more than one of you will
be thinking but let's see Josh how can
we prevent this kafala system from
perpetuating itself over time well some
steps are already being taken check it
out
highs and lows of Qatar
Qatar has announced many times that it
plans to improve the conditions endured
by its workers however years went by
without significant and changes despite
increasing International pressure the
current Emir took office in 2013. in his
first years he devoted himself to
Bringing order to the country's
administration because it was often
unclear who really wielded power in
Qatar whether it was the government or a
multitude of parallel agencies in the
end he replaced the prime minister in
2020 and the changes started to come
take a look Qatar enacts minimum wage
worker reforms as World Cup news reforms
are intended to dismantle kafala
sponsorship system the new labor laws
have changed radically in Qatar so much
so that legally there is no longer a
kafala the consent of the employer the
former kefil is no longer required to
change jobs or leave the country
according to official data around 350
000 people have already changed jobs
since 2020. as you can imagine the fact
that workers can resign is a small
incentive for the employer to at least
treat them with dignity regarding the
minimum wage it has been set to 1 000
Qatari Rials which is equivalent to
around 260 euros the minimum wage is
accompanied by a minimum allowance of 80
Euros for food and 130 Euros for housing
unless the employer provides both let's
not kid ourselves this minimum wage is
quite low however Qatar is the first
country in the Gulf to approve a minimum
wage for all workers anyway Qatar and
all the countries that worked with the
kafalis system are encountering the same
problem a legal change can be made but
now the most important thing is still
missing making the cultural change
[Music]
some employers are still reluctant to
accept the free movement of workers many
still encounter obstacles when leaving
one job and changing to another
retaliation by their employers Is
frequent one of the most common is to
maneuver for them to lose their
residence permits and report them as
having absconded which can lead to
deportation back to their countries of
origin
a very clever changing guitar is that
salaries must now be paid by bank
transfer to workers this small detail
offers them guarantees that workers will
be able to prove whether or not their
boss owes them money in addition to
cover non-payments the Qatari government
launched a workers support Fund in 2019.
it has since dispersed 320 million
dollars
a temporary period during which outdoor
work is prohibited from June to
mid-september has also been increased to
include the hottest 5.5 hours in the
middle of the day and not only that from
now on construction workers must stop
working anytime the temperature exceeds
32 degrees Celsius all these
developments in Qatar have been
developed in collaboration with the
international labor organization an
agency belonging to the UN that opened a
mission in Qatar in 2018 its latest
report on the country gives a mixed
picture Katara workers welfare reforms
means but challenges remain in summary
the ILO recognizes that the conditions
of thousands of workers have improved
but Qatar must make every effort to
ensure that labor laws are enforced
human rights ngos such as Amnesty
International agree because we are
talking about the same old problem the
law is one thing and another is to go
after those who break the law no matter
how much Qatar says we have abolished
slavery look at our laws nothing will
have been achieved if there is nothing
to force employers to comply with the
law these are areas where there is still
room for Improvement but now the
question is over to you do you think
that the legal change is introduced by
Qatar are enough or are workers still
completely helpless should we continue
to put pressure on all countries that
have kefala or is it none of our
business you can leave me your answers
in the comments and as always don't
forget that we have new videos every
week so subscribe to the channel so you
don't miss any of our updates if you
like this video like it and I'll see you
in the next one take care see you soon
[Music]